[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, let us finish.
[SPEAKER_06]: So that whole amount is?
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: It don't make sense.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's not much.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's not very nice.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's sense, but it doesn't make sense.
[SPEAKER_04]: Principle.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: He did a nice job the other night.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, he did, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I had never met him, but he was very empathetic, and I just thought he really made it.
[SPEAKER_06]: It was just a really good session, I thought.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, I bet he would be a great preacher.
[SPEAKER_06]: He is a preacher.
[SPEAKER_06]: Very good.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, that's what I said.
[SPEAKER_06]: I said, he said you should hear him preach.
[SPEAKER_06]: I said, I bet he would be a great preacher.
[SPEAKER_07]: What's his name?
[SPEAKER_07]: St. Pierre.
[SPEAKER_07]: And where is his church?
[SPEAKER_04]: Regal Christian.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, that's where Hunter's wanting to go.
[SPEAKER_07]: For Jet Robinson.
[SPEAKER_07]: I had never met him before.
[SPEAKER_06]: He was impressive, I thought.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: What was the session about?
[SPEAKER_06]: Really?
[SPEAKER_01]: I've never heard of him.
[SPEAKER_04]: He was a big shot with Walmart.
[SPEAKER_04]: Really?
[SPEAKER_04]: And he had the number three store in the United States.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he just got tired of corporate world.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, I was impressed with his compassion, his deliverance, everything he did.
[SPEAKER_06]: It was just saying.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's a good answer.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, he is.
[SPEAKER_03]: He certainly is.
[SPEAKER_06]: There are some things that aren't pleasant to deal with, and he sure did a nice job, I think, making people feel comfortable.
[SPEAKER_06]: I agree.
[SPEAKER_08]: You're talking about the Colbert, that's the one in Washington, D.C.?
[SPEAKER_08]: That's what he told me, so.
[SPEAKER_08]: What's going on, though?
[SPEAKER_08]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yep, I had a call yesterday.
[SPEAKER_08]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_08]: We used to have an entrance in front of the closet on the side.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yeah, I'll let them know.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yeah, I mean, this wouldn't necessarily go out to anybody, but yeah, I'll let them know.
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay, yeah, I'll let them know.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yeah, I'll let them know.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't think we really got a report back on that.
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_04]: One of them just ran it in one prescription, but it never appeared back.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yeah, all of them.
[SPEAKER_05]: What is this?
[SPEAKER_05]: I guess I don't get that.
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, the prescriptions are just this.
[SPEAKER_05]: What is that?
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know.
That's the number that's back.
Yeah, I'm going to let them know after we have a connection this morning.
[SPEAKER_08]: So when I'm done, I'll call and put a number back.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: No.
[SPEAKER_07]: You can, yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: Did you have a question?
[SPEAKER_07]: No, I was just thinking about a question that had been asked yesterday.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_07]: 7,607.
[SPEAKER_07]: I don't know if you've talked to anybody about it.
[SPEAKER_08]: And if you do, you can go on the right hand side.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's the final.
[SPEAKER_08]: We still have.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yeah, if you email those to me.
[SPEAKER_08]: 500,000 left on them.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yeah, if you just go ahead and send the photo.
[SPEAKER_08]: I'll make sure that Clay does that too as well.
[SPEAKER_08]: Oh, yeah, but for that.
[SPEAKER_04]: I do not know the answer to that, but she's going to yell at me.
[SPEAKER_06]: You gave us a report?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_06]: Right.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yeah, I know.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yes, sir.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'll call.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'll talk to you soon.
[SPEAKER_07]: This is Diamond Lower.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yes, of course.
[SPEAKER_07]: $17,000 for not just me.
[SPEAKER_07]: Bye.
[SPEAKER_07]: I mean, we still have the total, but we're not going beyond that.
[SPEAKER_07]: Right.
[SPEAKER_07]: So even with this, there's 500.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: $500?
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, $5,000.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_07]: But I didn't know if this was ready to be paid.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, if we pay it, you know, I'm fine paying it, but when we hit that number, that's it.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't care.
[SPEAKER_06]: It doesn't matter.
[SPEAKER_07]: We still have a waste bill on Homestead.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know the answer to that.
[SPEAKER_06]: Trina will do.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm going to hold that because I talked to him at length yesterday on that.
[SPEAKER_07]: So if you would hang on to that, talk to plague for quite a while on that.
[SPEAKER_03]: And so,
having it sent to this address here, the bills, the parts of the bills, because sometimes they'll deliver the parts up there, and that one's shed, so they have it delivered to this one.
What else do we have in the bills for there?
Well, you can't do that.
[SPEAKER_07]: So I called 9-1-1, and I'm like, we can't put an employee's address for where the bills go, so they have it corrected in the system, but these are old invoices from January.
[SPEAKER_07]: That one was a January one, and this one is a February one, because he wasn't, not Clay, but I think it was John,
[SPEAKER_07]: was giving them and not bringing them up.
[SPEAKER_07]: So we've gotten it taken care of with diamond mowers where they know, it's fine, ship it there, but build here.
[SPEAKER_06]: And that might be some of the issues that we have here that we're not getting enough invoices.
[SPEAKER_06]: So they all stack up.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, good, just that.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's probably clear as a bell, but not to me.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: I got this one.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's because if it happens at the jail, it's one way.
[SPEAKER_06]: Then if it happens through emergency room or hospital, it goes through a different pharmacy.
[SPEAKER_06]: So this here is for emergency room.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's all the ER stuff.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Or if they have to go in.
[SPEAKER_06]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think we're finished signing invoices.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's a nice feeling.
[SPEAKER_06]: Until next time.
[SPEAKER_06]: And Melissa gave us everything.
[SPEAKER_06]: We're going to do that tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_06]: And we had talked about a couple times the...
[SPEAKER_06]: the concern about the Kratom and the synthetic 7-OH products in Ray County, also in the state.
[SPEAKER_06]: And we did some investigating.
[SPEAKER_06]: We reached out to the city of Kansas City.
[SPEAKER_06]: They gave us information on kind of, they have a lot of legal people that's kind of looking at these issues.
[SPEAKER_06]: So we took what they gave us.
[SPEAKER_06]: They did make an ordinance.
[SPEAKER_06]: And we took that information and kind of narrowed it down, and we do have a resolution to consider.
[SPEAKER_06]: And maybe, shall I just read the resolution?
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: And we have had our legal look at this.
[SPEAKER_06]: A resolution of the County Commission of Ray County, Missouri, expressing concern about kratom and synthetic 7-OH products and urging state action.
[SPEAKER_06]: Whereas kratom and synthetic 7OH products are being sold in Missouri's gas stations, convenience stores, and specialty shops, often marketed as legal, natural, or energy products.
[SPEAKER_06]: And whereas these products can act
[SPEAKER_06]: on opioid receptors carrying risks of dependence and serious health effects and have raised significant public health and public safety concerns.
[SPEAKER_06]: And whereas the Missouri Attorney General has opened investigation into Kratom manufacturers and retailers for potentially deceptive and unsafe practices, warning that Missourians may be misled about the safety and contents of these products.
[SPEAKER_06]: Now, therefore, be it resolved by the Ray County Commission of Ray County that the commissions recognize Kratom Synthetic 7-OH and related products as a serious public health and public safety concern in Ray County and across Missouri.
[SPEAKER_06]: The commission urges parents, schools, health care providers, and community organizations to increase awareness of the risks of these products and to discourage their use.
[SPEAKER_06]: The Commission respectfully urges the Missouri General Assembly to adopt a clear regulatory framework for kratom, including age 21 limits and basic product standards, and to ban or strictly regulate 7OH and similar high-risk products, with meaningful penalties for manufacturers and retail.
[SPEAKER_06]: The Commission supports continued efforts by the Attorney General and law enforcement agencies to investigate and take appropriate action against companies that deceptively market or sell unsafe Kratom or OH products in Missouri.
[SPEAKER_06]: This is for our consideration.
[SPEAKER_03]: I make a motion to accept the resolution.
[SPEAKER_04]: I second that.
[SPEAKER_06]: All those in favor?
[SPEAKER_06]: Aye.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, we will sign this.
[SPEAKER_06]: It took us a little while to get through all this, but what, three or four months?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there not room to take action within Ray County of limiting it?
[SPEAKER_03]: As we research this, the county commission does not have the authority to pass regulations.
[SPEAKER_03]: The state does.
[SPEAKER_03]: There's actually several bills in the works that address this, and so if anybody wants to understand what's going on, I would recommend checking with the state.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I have checked with some of our, I haven't checked, I can't say I've checked with all of our stores, but almost everyone I have checked with has taken it off the shelves, which at least the attention to this has gotten us that far.
[SPEAKER_06]: We did.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: We do not have, we're going to table the sheriff's office until tomorrow, correct?
[SPEAKER_06]: And the next thing on the agenda is the sunshine request charges.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Now, I know we had a little bit of this discussion.
[SPEAKER_06]: We are receiving a lot of them.
[SPEAKER_06]: So we are wanting to figure out what the criteria is and the parameters that we need to follow
[SPEAKER_06]: to be able to provide the answers to those requests.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I believe that Heather is talking to Travis about that.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I would like to table this till next week, till we have in front of us what some of the parameters and options are for us.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'd like the motion to table it until we get it from legal.
[SPEAKER_06]: I second that.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm a joke.
[SPEAKER_06]: Is there any other business that should come before the commission?
[SPEAKER_06]: Any questions?
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you have any questions for Annie?
[SPEAKER_06]: You look like you're wanting to ask a question.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: If there are no further items to come before the commission, do you want to...
[SPEAKER_06]: I have to leave here, but not for, we could wait until 10 o'clock if you wanted.
[SPEAKER_06]: So we'll just leave the meeting over until 10.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: We will need to talk to Clay about that diamond mower.
[SPEAKER_03]: They were trying to explain it to me over the phone.
[SPEAKER_03]: I said, I'm going to have to stand there and look at it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Show me what's wrong with it.
[SPEAKER_03]: It seems that there may be a problem with factory parking.
[SPEAKER_03]: The factory is saying, well, we've got something waiting to go under in places.
[SPEAKER_03]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: Here's how that happened.
[SPEAKER_03]: And the factory said, we're going to send you an example out of our good graces.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_07]: Are the charges publicly available somewhere from the Sunshine stuff?
[SPEAKER_06]: I do not know the answers to that question.
[SPEAKER_03]: It will be if it's not.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, it's like a lot of things.
[SPEAKER_03]: We came in and we don't know.
[SPEAKER_03]: And the salaries have changed, so that number should probably change too.
[SPEAKER_03]: But it does say in the book that it's an average of the clerical employees' salaries.
[SPEAKER_06]: The lowest paying.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, the lowest paying.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, to find documents.
[SPEAKER_04]: So do you know what the charges are?
[SPEAKER_01]: I was just charged $9 an hour this last time, but I think that's what they're changing.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, this is Sheila Tracy again.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I wanted to clarify and confirm that you received my message that we did not have a current contract with you as far as for fertilizing.
[SPEAKER_06]: So we just want to be sure you realize that we do not have an ongoing relationship for that service.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_05]: I hope not, please.
[SPEAKER_06]: I have not seen him.
[SPEAKER_06]: How big was the biggest hail that everybody in Ray County got?
[SPEAKER_08]: I know, I was wondering that earlier, too.
[SPEAKER_06]: We had probably dime-sized, but some of the pictures were just...
[SPEAKER_02]: I didn't get me an Excelsior, not where I was, but I felt like the worst mom in the world because I had to take my kid to a school board meeting with me last night, and then the sirens start going off when I'm trying to leave, and I was like, sorry, kid.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, it wasn't...
[SPEAKER_08]: 80 degrees right before the thunder started.
[SPEAKER_03]: It was interesting because the sirens went off here and I think it had kind of passed us about that time.
[SPEAKER_03]: I never know what the sirens are for.
[SPEAKER_03]: Are they tornado sirens or are they storm sirens?
[SPEAKER_04]: They're just a warning that something is going on and being ready to
[SPEAKER_04]: It's just a general warning.
[SPEAKER_04]: General warning.
[SPEAKER_06]: But my phone went off last night.
[SPEAKER_03]: I had to shut my phone off.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, when it was the warning, I mean, my phone doesn't usually do that.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, it just flared kind of like out of those big chills.
[SPEAKER_06]: And it was like...
[SPEAKER_06]: I think we should go to the basement.
[SPEAKER_06]: When you're married to a farmer, they just kind of drag their feet.
[SPEAKER_06]: They're not very pro-safety at our house.
[SPEAKER_06]: Or go outside and look.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's what you do.
[SPEAKER_06]: And watch it come towards your house.
[SPEAKER_02]: Everyone have a good day.
[SPEAKER_02]: You too, Bree.
[SPEAKER_02]: Have a great day.
[SPEAKER_02]: You too.
[SPEAKER_06]: Bree, if you would put that resolution in a file too.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then these, or do you already have these emails in it?
[SPEAKER_06]: This email.
[SPEAKER_08]: Oh, I can.
[SPEAKER_08]: I'll just put that in.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I want to consider and think about whether I really want to go to these meetings on Wednesday of March.
[SPEAKER_03]: I wish you would.
[SPEAKER_05]: And you feel that one in particular is one that you have to be at.
[SPEAKER_06]: I thought maybe sometimes.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't feel like in particular I have to be at any of them yet.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm still trying to figure out how to make my attendance there effective for Lake County.
[SPEAKER_06]: What I...
[SPEAKER_06]: What I would suggest, and I don't know on those committees because I don't look at that, but I would look specifically and I would talk to the staff and say, I would like the agenda for this meeting.
[SPEAKER_06]: And if there is nothing on there that is pertaining or pertinent or a big deal to our county,
[SPEAKER_06]: I still think you're the right person to be there, if it's a big deal.
[SPEAKER_06]: But if it's just a regular meeting where they're giving you updates, and I think you can get that off your agenda.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's what I would suggest.
[SPEAKER_06]: I know you can't be in two places at once.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right now, we have the opportunity to recommend things for the unfiltered needs list.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I think that's the only place that we can do that.
[SPEAKER_03]: All of your projects have to
[SPEAKER_03]: follow through their priorities.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know, they have a list of priorities.
[SPEAKER_03]: You have to fit in that list of priorities to your project building.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yesterday, there were a little short projects on the zero side.